(audience cheers)
- It's nice to see you.
- Hello, it's good to see you.
- Hello, we did an interview
together the other day
and I don't remember your
hair looking this fabulous.
- I think I was wearing a hat, maybe.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay, I don't
know, I love the longer look.
- It's too long.
- Is it? You're gonna cut it?
- [Nick] I don't know.
- Don't do it.
- Well...
(audience yelling)
- It looks so cool.
You've got the natural curl
thing going, it's cool.
- Well, thanks.
- [Kelly] Just saying.
- I just get frustrated having
to do it in the morning.
- Says every woman on the planet,
join us. (audience laughs) Yeah, yeah.
Did you make any resolutions for 23?
- I didn't make any resolutions,
but I have a few things on
my mind, goals and ambitions.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I feel like with the resolutions,
it's kind of like set up for-
- Failure?
- [Nick] Failure every time.
So I just kinda approached it with some
some personal goals,
some professional goals.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, there's a lot
on the personal front.
Obviously being a new father.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So that's taking up- (audience cheers)
- [Kelly] You're gonna try
and get sleep this year?
- most of my time.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I was
like, there's no sleeping
when they're that young.
- What about you? Did you-
Your daughter turned one though, right?
- Um, she's-
- [Kelly] Or she's about to turn one?
- She did.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, well over the weekend.
- [Kelly] Okay, over the
weekend she turned one.
- So um, she's amazing.
- [Kelly] Okay, did you throw a big party?
- We did, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- You know, we had to celebrate.
She went through a pretty wild journey-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
in the early part of her life.
And so we had to celebrate in style.
- Yeah.
- She's one, she's
beautiful, it's amazing.
- [Kelly] She's adorable.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- The best.
- Growing up did you ever do anything
that kind of worried your parents?
Were you, not a good kid,
but were you one they didn't worry about,
or one they were like,
"Oh he's gonna try and jump off the roof?"
- So, here's the deal,
is that I was actually
really well behaved.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Whereas Joe and Kevin at times were not.
- Look at that.
- I don't know, you look
like Dennis the Menace there.
I'm just saying.
- But then there would
be these streaks of,
I remember my first time ever swimming.
We lived in this apartment
complex in Dallas, Texas.
And there was a fence around the pool
and it was the start of the winter season.
So not only was it cold,
but also the pool was shut and locked.
Because it was dangerous
for kids to go swimming.
But for some reason at like
three or four years old
I just decided it would be a
good idea to like hop the fence
and just go for a swim.
And my mom of course, like
ran after me as I just
like climbed over this fence.
And so I would do these things
that were so outta character
and just like nearly fatal.
And, and-
- Boys do that.
- [Nick] Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- I recognize my mom was very patient
and I'm sure I gave her a lot of scares.
But yeah, other than that
I was pretty well behaved.
Apart from nearly drowning.
- Apart from nearly dying in a pool.
Oh my gosh, I can't imagine.
I put my kids in swim lessons
because they were babies.
Because I was so worried about that.
You heard those horror stories.
I feel like you're probably
the most patient dad on planet Earth.
Are you?
- I mean, I try to be.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Our dad was very patient.
- Well you and John, when I
work with you on the Voice,
I feel like you're both kind of,
you could both be walking Ambien.
You're both that chill.
They're both that chill-
- Thank you?
- I know I think because I'm opposite.
I'm always like (imitating bird)
- [Nick] But John especially.
- John especially, he is the one
I actually call walking Ambien, yes.
- He is so chill.
- He is so chill that
I thought he was stoned
every time I saw him.
Turns out he doesn't even get high.
I was like, "what"?
It was the craziest thing ever
finding that information out.
But I feel like you're
a really patient dad,
that's gonna serve you well.
Because you're gonna need it.
- Yeah, she hasn't started walking yet,
but I'm sure when she does...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's gonna be patience
and comfortable shoes.
Because I'll be running after her.
- 100%, and just getting old
because you turned 30 last year,
so you're gonna need those Dr. Scholl's.
- Yes. Oh I have insoles
in my shoes right now.
- [Kelly] I have insoles.
- So wait, do you turn 30?
Did you do a big thing?
Are you excited to be 30?
- We did a thing, we
went to my favorite place
in the world.
It's a golf spot in Scottsdale, Arizona.
- Oh.
- And had some friends out
and we did a little golf tournament.
And it was really fun.
You know, the whole kind of weekend
was birthday activities.
But I will say that 30-
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- You know, it hits different.
- Yeah.
- [Nick] It's not like-
- Wait till 40. (audience laughs)
- Yeah, but it, and I say this knowing
I sound ridiculous.
I go into it knowing full
well that someone older
than me would say, "Yeah,
that you're ridiculous,
you're only 30."
But the jump from the hangover at 29
to the hangover at 30
was very real for me.
- Yeah, the recovery time.
- It was like, this is not fun.
I don't like this.
- Yeah.
- But I used to be able
to just bounce back
and I was fine.
And now it's like I don't
like the way I feel.
- Well just so you know
when you get to 40,
literally it's overnight.
You get out of bed and you're
like, "why does it hurt?"
I just got out of bed.
I should feel rested,
like what's happening?
Yeah, your actual body...
I don't know, you're kind of in shape.
Maybe it'll be different for you.
(audience cheers)
So you and your brothers
are headed back to Vegas.
I love your show.
So tell us about the show.
And I love this photo shoot too.
Whose idea was it to sit
in the middle of the road?
- Well, back to my jumping in the pool
and nearly, it was probably my idea.
Let's sit in the middle of the road.
- [Kelly] Let's play chicken.
- Yeah. So the Vegas shows are amazing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I love playing these shows.
And you obviously do
your Vegas shows as well.
But you just get such an
interesting collection
of people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, you know, our fans are the best fans
in the world.
And they're traveling
from all over the world
to come to these shows,
spending their own hard earned money and-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's really like, it's
been a moment for all of us
as we step into this kind of next chapter
of our life and career
where we're just so grateful
to have the support we've had for so long.
And now, a place like Vegas where our fans
can come and just celebrate
and meet other fans
and have a good time.
That's been one of the coolest things too,
is seeing people connect
who didn't know each other
before the weekend.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they come out and
have a great time, and-
- [Kelly] I love that in meet and greets
when fans say that, "oh, we actually met
at one of your shows."
And I'm like, that's cool.
It's like Jesus, bringing people together.
- Just like him.
- We're doing more of those.
- I have to ask though, is it easy though?
Because you know, you have a kid now,
so it's better right?
Because it's in one place.
You're just going to one place instead
of touring all over all the time.
- Well, what I was gonna say was yes.
There is that aspect of it
and it's close enough to L.A.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But later this year
there will be a tour.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- A tour. (audience cheers)
- Are you bringing the fam?
Here's why I'm saying it,
I love my children more
than anything on this planet
but it is really hard
to tour with children.
- Yeah, I've never-
- If you're a present
parent it is very hard.
Because you're singing so late at night
so it's like waking up early with them
because they don't know
you're singing late at night.
So they wake up at 6:00 AM and
it's just a different thing.
Like tour, I'm just, good luck.
- Do your kids wear the headphones?
- [Kelly] They do.
- Yeah. It's the cutest thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it is.
- I will probably be
hitting you up for advice
on how we should structure it
because I've never done it.
- Yeah.
- Kevin and Joe have had kids on the road
but this'll be our first venture with it.
But I'm excited for all of it
and this year's gonna be
very busy, but very fun.
- Is easier with one, I
remember when I first did it
with River, like it was easier with one
to kind of keep up with that.
Once you start adding,
(laughs) you're like,
"and you get to stay home
while mommy goes to work."
- Yeah.
- So wait, do you guys
have any music coming out?
Asking for a friend, what?
I love y'all.
- Yeah. So the album is done.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Okay. (audience cheers)
- We are very excited about it.
And we're kind of in that planning moment.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Planning the campaign.
- [Kelly] Yeah. I am too.
- The album.
- Same boat, yeah.
- Yeah. The single, like all the things.
(audience cheers)
- The thing I...
I cannot wait to hear it
but the thing I love
about your band as well
is I love y'all separately too.
I love the projects
you've done outside too.
Like the solo stuff, like
everything is awesome.
And that doesn't usually happen.
You know what I'm saying?
Sometimes in groups, like people,
I mean, not saying
anything about anybody else
I just mean like some people release stuff
and you're like, "I wasn't
as into it as the other one."
You know, but y'all have
released stuff that's so cool.
And as a whole you're still solid.
It's amazing.
And I don't know if that's
because the family dynamic
and where y'all are at in
life, but it's so good.
I love y'all separately.
I love you together.
You're just a very talented family.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
It wasn't a question,
yeah, just a statement.
(audience cheers)
Okay, so when we were
doing research on you,
that means I was just stalking you online.
My team came across some Nick Jonas facts.
Okay, so-
- [Nick] Oh, interesting.
- There's a lot of lies out there.
- [Nick] There are.
(Kelly laughs)
- And there's a lot of truth.
So we wanna know if you will answer these?
Like what is fact and what is fiction?
- Oh, interesting, yes,
love to.
- Okay.
- You don't have a choice, so here we go.
Okay, (Kelly laughs) welcome to my show.
Okay, so Nick Jonas can't whistle?
- Um...
- [Kelly] You can't whistle?
- That is a fact. (Kelly whistles)
- [Kelly] What?
- I have newly discovered-
- [Kelly] Okay.
- that I can make a sound
that is a whistle sound.
- That was sad. (Kelly laughs)
- But I can't whistle a tune.
- Oh okay.
- So, I can't whistle a song,
but I can just go... (whistles)
(everyone laughs)
That's the extent of my
whistle. (Nick laughs)
- That was like the saddest
whistle heard around the world.
- And sometimes I can't even get it.
- And sometimes it's
just air. (Kelly laughs)
Okay, I did not know that about you.
Okay, Nick Jonas's favorite
part of the cake is the icing.
- That's kind of a fact.
- Okay, I like the combo,
the cake and the icing.
- I like them both too, but-
- It's nice chemistry.
- I'm not like a big cake guy.
I actually have pie on
on my birthday instead.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love pie.
- I'm a big pumpkin pie guy.
- That's my favorite pie.
- Best pie.
- Oh.
- Hands down.
So the whole thing, the cake part,
I could just kind of dip my finger
and enjoy the icing and then be done.
And then go get a pie. (audience laughs)
- I will say pie is better.
Pie is better than cake.
I'm with you.
Okay. Okay.
Nick was in a Chuck E. Cheese commercial
when he was younger?
- What do you think the answer is?
- I think that would be super cool.
I love Chuck E. Cheese, even
at 40, like with my kids.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so I loved Chuck
E. Cheese when I was a kid.
I think that would be really cool.
And I feel like you're cool.
So you probably did do that.
- I did that. (audience cheers)
- You did that.
You did that.
What was the commercial?
Did you get to hang with
the band, like the mouse?
Did you get to-
- So when I was a kid
and I was doing acting
in Broadway and music and stuff-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I would go on auditions
for things all the time.
And there was two big jobs that you wanted
to get as a child actor.
- Yeah.
- In the Northeast.
One was the Hess Truck
holiday commercials.
I don't know if you've ever seen those.
- What is that?
- But it was like a big deal.
- Okay.
- It was a song, it was a
whole thing and I never got it.
- [Kelly] Ah.
- I was so mad.
But I did get the other, I would say,
second most desirable
job for a child actor.
- Well I've never heard of that.
And I've heard of Chuck E. Cheese.
I think you won.
- Because it's a national commercial.
Whereas the Hess truck was
a local commercial, I think.
But the national commercial
was Chuck E. Cheese.
And I got it.
And I got to do this cool
thing where I'm sitting
on like the Skee-Ball thing.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And I threw it behind
my back and it went up
and went into the the thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we did the first shot and I got it.
I actually got it in cause
they were gonna like CGI it.
And I got a high five
from the director and-
- Yeah.
- From Chuck E. Cheese himself.
- You're on cloud nine.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, It's pretty cool.
- That's cool.
- And they gave me a thousand tokens.
- [Kelly] Whoa.
- Which is like equivalent
to like, I think-
- Winning the lottery as a child-
- Two dollars, yeah.
- But, yeah.